probably the most despicable tactic of
the left among all their other
despicable tactics like describing
anything they don't agree with as
misinformation and constantly claiming
that their political opponents are not
just wrong but morally inferior is the
way the left has engaged in a non-stop
smear really for years now trying to
brand every republican every
conservative everyone that's not on
their team as a racist it is utterly
disgusting just as racism itself is
utterly disgusting in fact it's
precisely because racism is so
disgusting that falsely smearing someone
as a racist is so vile
ilhan omar was at it again this morning
this is who they are their party
right now is normalizing
anti-muslim bigotry
falsely smearing people as racist is
itself bigotry
but so is this frankly
well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
[Applause]
look i know there's a massive double
standard here islamophobic remarks from
lauren bobert are disgusting and
unacceptable just as anti-semitic
remarks from ilhan omar are disgusting
and unacceptable yet the media demand
condemnation of one but not the other
but there's a wider context
as we have laid out many times the
places in america that you see the worst
outcomes for black people latinos asian
americans are places run by democrats
it's not racism that causes much of the
racial injustice in america today it is
far left democrat policies exactly the
kind of policies championed by ilhan
omar so you have to ask yourself why do
so many of the victims of these policies
continue to vote democrat
a big part of it is the democrats racism
smear republicans are racist they scream
you can't vote for them but the truth is
we're not going to turn things around in
places like chicago or here in
california where i live unless they do
vote republican
if you love america you hate to see
what's happening in blue states and blue
cities it is horrible
we need change we need a revolution a
political revolution where the
republican party becomes what we have
long argued for here a multi-racial
working class coalition
now we know that whatever we do or say
the democrats and their media stooges
will call republicans racist dogs bark
cats meow democrats call their opponents
racists
but we don't have to make it easy for
them we don't have to help them in their
smears every time a republican comes out
with some stupid comment that confirms
the left's caricature it sets back our
progress in building that multi-racial
working-class coalition yes i know bobot
apologized and i know ilhan omar is
never held accountable by pelosi or the
media for her bigotry i know biden
himself runs around calling his black
aids boy and clearly has a racist
mindset but so what is that the plan now
to be as bad as them no let's be better
than them
how hard is it for republican leaders to
condemn bigoted stupidities
how hard is it for republican members of
congress to behave like responsible
adults instead of vacuous teenagers on
snapchat calling the other girls trash
and how hard is it for these politicians
like lauren bobert in safe districts to
understand that while they can say what
they like and still get elected in
places like chicago and california it's
hard work being a republican we're up
against years of smears and false
propaganda so could you stop being so
selfish
think before you speak
and show everyone that conservatives are
not just not racist
but in fact have the ideas that will
bring about what we all want to see
equal opportunity for every american of
every race hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else